can you imagine him accepting Islam
muhammadan rasulullah
wow mashallah I feel like a new man I'm
someone who who's been very critical of
trump I love the Muslims I think they're
great people I consider my Muslim
Americans to be an important
what putting one in your cabinet or on
your ticket a Muslim American
Muslim oh absolutely no problem with
that would I consider putting a Muslim
American in my cabinet absolutely no
problem with that
definitely think that Muslims pose a
danger to this country I love the
Muslims I think they're great people
Muslims we got to be fair
nonpartisan we're about justice so again
as somebody I've been critical of trump
Obama uh Bush Clinton you name them I'm
I I've probably sued them I have sued
president Trump over his reasons
I mean it was clear he said he wants a
total complete shutdown of Muslims from
entering the country and then he banned
uh a number of muslim-majority countries
from from being able to send people here
the last time we gave a shout out to
actually his boy uh tarot uh tuckerson
oh yeah yeah maybe they start having
Trump have a change now too also I love
the Muslims I think they're great people
there's a lot of background to that look
I think Trump was susceptible to some
bad influences like Steve Bannon and
others that tried to hijack him for his
agenda
um and I think absent that maybe things
could have gone a much better Direction
but that's neither here nor there the
point is the reason I'm mentioning this
is people know I'm certainly no Fanboy
in fact I've sued the guy but I'm I'm
deeply Disturbed what I see unfolding
the reason is this I mean ultimately I
think there's two questions that are
relevant
number one is did Trump break the law
number two is is the prosecution uh
politically driven and frankly I think
the answer to both of those is yes and
and both of those is alarming see when
it comes to the first did Trump break
the law the fact is there's over 50 000
federal laws a Harvard study has shown
that the average American commits three
felonies a felony is a crime punishable
by over a year in jail the average
American they say commits three felonies
a day wow three a day three a day
because there's over fifty thousand and
how do you're not committing it if you
don't know them and how the heck are you
gonna know fifty thousand laws and
that's why as a lawyer I always say
never speak to the FBI without a lawyer
I stand by it you know uh if they ever
contact you contact care uh contact my
Law Firm care we'll do it for free I'll
charge you but but we'll give you good
legal representation but reach out you
know and never speak to them without a
lawyer because it's easy to get yourself
in trouble you don't know the law the
point is there's over 50 000 federal
laws the average American breaks about
three laws a year uh a day why did I say
this because if the full force and power
of the governor government wants to come
after you they can pretty much come
after anyone you know imagine if they
did what they're doing the dates they
just lock you up until they find
something they're bound to find
something on someone even if it's
inadvertent so the point is there's too
many federal laws out there America has
some of the highest incarceration rates
in the world it's a problem and and so
yeah I think he broke the law but
frankly I think
just about all of those politicians have
broken the law but they're selectively
Prosecuting him for political reasons
and I think that's disturbing I also
think it's a reflection of the of how
both the left and the right have used
anti-muslim hate before it was the
Muslim Community getting the brunt of
this extreme prosecution extreme hate
now it's being thrown against each other
and the other thing is all right you
want to prosecute uh Trump for paying a
a hundred thousand dollars uh in hush
money payments and whatever stupid
nonsense all of these Hypocrites are
engaged in Washington DC what are you
going to prosecute uh other presidents
that have killed hundreds of thousands
of innocent civilians made illegal Wars
destroyed Nations so please spare me
with your your cries about justice so
frankly I think as an attorney the you
know again as somebody who hasn't been a
fan of trump I think yeah he's broken
the law but so is every other American
because America's uh is over
criminalizes its people
and I think that kind of prosecution
therefore is political I think there was
increased uh focus on him and I think
there was ignoring others that have done
worse things like
uh crimes against humanity war crimes
illegal Wars and uh it's disturbing to
see to to see that the people who
literally have blood on their hands get
off I mean as far as I know and correct
me if I'm wrong but I don't know if
Trump has invaded any Muslim lands or
has caused any new Wars while in office
and you know a lot of people would argue
against me because I was you know maybe
too critical of trump but that was one
thing they always had on me you know you
know they would always say well listen
at least he didn't start any new
Bloodshed against Muslim nations or or
any Nation for that matter so this is
the problem it's overly criminalized and
I think the the we're just seeing what's
been happening in the Muslim Community
for a long time and for a very long time
the Muslim Community was being
selectively prosecuted and now that
those same tactics are just being used
against each other
um but it sets quite a interesting
precedent I don't think as the president
or former president he should get a free
pass to break the law and maybe there
are other things perhaps related to the
election in Georgia perhaps related to
the riots that that maybe are more
appropriate to pursue but the current
charges out of New York do seem to be
deeply politically driven and it's a
stretch of the law at best and it
appears to be selectively a selective
prosecution which again I think just
opens the door and just shows how in
this country they can really be there's
so many federal laws they can come
against anyone I'm a lawyer but I'm not
a big fan of our justice system I do
think our justice system is better than
most other nations that being said it's
it's uh still got a long way to go and I
think Trump
he needs Islam also amen I think uh I
don't think he's too really um involved
here I think I don't know correct me if
I'm wrong that he plays this card to go
ahead and win a certain side but uh only
Allah knows what's in his heart as far
as because he comes out he's a Christian
correct well I I definitely think Trump
is just you know catering to some bad
influences you know uh you know you see
how he gets along by the way in Saudi
Arabia and the parties they have for him
I I don't think uh you know I I I think
he's equally ignorant to a lot of
different cultures and a lot of
different sensitivities it's just how he
is and he's very transparent and honest
about it uh you know but you know on the
other hand you have others on the
Democrats side
what their soul hides is worth so some
people may pretend to be our friends uh
but what is hidden within their whole uh
Hearts is a lot of animosity but Trump
you know what you're getting you know
what you're getting and I this let's
close with this sincerity I don't think
any human being who's sincere and asks
the creator of the heavens and the Earth
for guidance be it Trump being anybody
that God Almighty Allah not guide them
so I think if someone is intelligent as
can be as any politician Donald Trump or
whatnot he's made amass a lot of money
he's he's uh one of the most influential
human beings now on the planet he's
running for president again if he was to
look and to read this book objectively
with a sincere open heart open mind can
you imagine him except in
islamadan rasulullah
wow mashallah I feel like a new man plug
item nothing is difficult for Allah and
look I mean I've compared him to karun
sometimes somebody who is wealthy and
arrogant and misguided but the fact is
no one is be beyond the mercy of Allah
if they sincerely seek it so we hope
guidance for him we hope guidance really
for all Humanity go ahead no you're
going no I like what you said the last
time we met that Allah is Mercy is
encompassing we cannot restrict it now
that's it that's it and ultimately man
that's what matters look and when you
die it doesn't matter if you're a
Democrat or Republican it doesn't matter
how much money you got in the bank
matters is do you know your lord and
that's what our purpose is to call
people to that above all else to know
who they are and they cannot know who
they are if they don't know where they
came from and they cannot know where
they came from they don't know where
they're going death is inevitable our
meeting with our Lord is inevitable let
us know and meet our know our Lord
before we meet our Lord remember death
remember death all that money everything
that you're going to uh accumulate in
this life is going to stay behind well
and that's why we see many wealthy you
know whether they're athletes
celebrities or you know uh men women who
live like party lifestyles in the U.S
drinking clubs all of that but you find
them leaving that
for Ramadan for fasting for wearing
hijab for a conservative Islamic
lifestyle because they see that
following and worshiping your desires
doesn't bring peace it brings misery but
knowing your lord is what brings peace
in this life and in the next and that's
why Islam continues to be the fastest
growing religion it's to liberate
Humanity from being enslaved and that's
what modern capitalist Society sort of
does to humanity it makes you sleep to
your desire sleep to your opinion of
others Islam liberates you that you
should only be a slave to your lord and
your lord only wants good for you
thank you my brother and we'll send
people here to the website you can get a
free copy of the Quran of this Quran
actually at the deaneshow.com go ahead
and visit us there and we'll send this
out to you as a gift and if you have any
other questions you can call us at
1-800-662 Islam and we'll be there to
help you along your way answer the
questions that you might have and we'll
see you next time here on the dean show
until then peace be with you assalamu
alaikum
foreign
[Music]
people worshiping the creation to
worshiping the Creator now Lord bless
your efforts Eddie
all right so you can see we're getting
to work and we need your support so go
ahead and help us to get this where it's
top-notch inshallah